>> So, it's my pleasure
to welcome Mark Briers to
MSR to give a talk
today entitled Turing,
Bayes and Cyber Security.
Mark is the Program Director of
Security the Alan
Turing Institute.
Prior to that he
worked for 16 years in
the Defense Industry primarily in
the areas of statistical
data analysis.
His research interests include
scalable bayesian inference,
sequential inference,
and anomaly detection,
particularly areas
of cyber security.
So thank you for doing
this talk today, Mark.
>> No, thank you. Thank you
for inviting me and thank you
for coming here on
early- is it Wednesday?
I've kind of- Wednesday
or Thursday.
I've lost count what day it is.
Jet lag and what gave you .
So thank you for
hosting me today.
So, what I want to do is
to split this talk
essentially into
three parts I think I
changed talk title as
well just to keep
us all on our toes.
So, what I want to
do is to discuss
the Alan Turing Institute
and introduce that to you.
Your organization and
hopefully motivate you,
inspire you and convince you that
it's a worthwhile opportunity
to collaborate with us,
if that's of interest
to you guys.
Then kind of in some
sense the segue from
Turing and the Turing Institutes
and Alan Turing the man
into the use of Bayesian
statistics in the context of
security related applications and
Turing's work at Bletchley Park.
So there's a couple
of slides on and
some relatively recent
publications of
Alan Turing's that've
been declassified
and pushed out that not
many people are aware of,
which demonstrate Turing's use
of Bayes which is quite
cool in my opinion.
Then finally, try
to kind of- there's
so many tenuous links
in this talk
and finally link the kind
of Bayesian story to my work in
cybersecurity and give you
an overview of what I'm
trying to achieve
with the work at
the institutes in the context
of cybersecurity.
My background is I'm
a statistician by kind of PhD.
Specifically sequential
Monte-Carlo that was
the subject of my PhD thesis.
So, you'll see lots of use
of those kinds of algorithms
and I've been taught
Bayesian statistics from
an undergraduate level.
So, all I know is
base so if there's
a question my solution
is a Bayesian solution,
so I will make
a slight apology for being
completely kind of shortsighted
in my approach to things.
So, the Alan Turing Institute,
I've got a few slides on
the Alan Turing institute.
So, we are a charity in the UK,
and we were set up by
the UK government,
well, formally announced
in March 2014.
And what was happening in
the UK and perhaps around
the world but specifically in
the context of the UK landscape,
there's lots of
work being done in,
well, I guess we know
call it data science,
perhaps we'd even call it
artificial intelligence given
the evolution of
the type that gets
such these data
related activities.
But back in the day it was
referred to as big data.
So, there are lots of
difference initiatives,
research initiatives or
application relation initiatives
happening in academia
and in industry.
There's lots of fragmentation
even within the UK.
So, the UK government's was
particularly keen to ensure
that UK society and
UK PLC can benefit
from these activities,
and so they set up
a National Institutes for data
science and artificial
intelligence related research
to provide national level
leadership and ensure
that UK society and
in collaboration with
our international partners
internationally we can
benefit from research activities
taking place in these areas.
So, the institutes-
and you can think
of as sitting at the center
of two networks.
On one hand we've
got a network of
academic related institutions and
I'll talk about that in
more detail shortly,
on the other side
we have a number
of industry or government
related partners through
which we try to kind of get
real-world problems and
ensure that our research has
real-world applicability.
Our job is essentially to try to
make some sense out of
all the stuff that's going
on in academia and industry,
connect things up and
provide strategic leadership
at the national level.
Alongside that were
also expected to
train and educate everybody
from some of my relatives
who know nothing
about data science all
the way through to
professors who want to know more
about a specific
specialized area.
So we're expected to kind of
provide training and
education as well.
So we've got quite agreement
and we get a
reasonable amounts of
funding from central government
which is actually
funneled through
one of our research council's,
similar to the NSF I guess.
So we're considered to be
a strategic government
investment.
That means that we're
not considered to be
predatory in any sense
because we are a charity,
we've got some
charitable goals around
social good and
training and education,
people don't see us as a threat,
a commercial threat or otherwise.
They see us as a
way in which they
can utilize our expertise
and the expertise
that we bring in to benefit
their organizations.
And in doing so we can benefit
or we can align ourselves
to our charitable goals.
So, we've got a network of
university partners and I'll
describe how that
works in a moment,
but these are the
university partners that we
have at the moment so
we started off with
five universities when we were
initially created so
we were announced by
George Osborne who was our
and it was our Chancellor of
the Exchequer back in 2014.
We kind of started in 2016
really doing any activity.
So October 2016, so
about two years old now.
We started with
five universities.
So, we had a competition
in the UK to decide
the five best universities
in data science and AI and
the top five one and there'll be
no surprises there in
terms of the names.
These are household names
in some respects.
Then in the past
six months we've increased
our network with
eight more universities.
We're now up to 13
universities, if I can count,
and what we do is we
essentially second
academics from universities
to work with us and
provide us with the
intellectual capital that we
need to be able to
undertake the research activities
that we wish to undertake.
I'll touch on that
like say in a moment.
Just to show you that
we're not London-centric.
So, the cool thing is that,
well, I think it's cool.
The cool thing is that
the Alan Turing Institute's
headquarters is
based in the British
Library in London.
So, if you ever get
across the London them do
please drop me
an email and my email
address is on the final slide.
Come visit us, because
the British library has
some cool artifacts and
some Mark McCarthy's
hosted there.
We actually have
an iPad coffee machine
which is another cool thing.
Maybe is not so cool.
In Microsoft you may
have those things.
But in the UK that's
kind of unique
so it's one of
the attracting things.
So Magna Carta and
iPad coffee machine,
if they can't attract you over
to the UK then I
don't know what will.
So, we're based in
London and we have
two university partners
also based in
London UCL and Queen Mary.
Then we have them universities
based around the country.
So, we have offices
in each one of
these locations and
I suspect we'll
have representation in
Northern Ireland and in Wales in
relatively short timescales
as well or I hope that
from a personal perspective
so that we have
full geographic coverage
across the UK.
So, that's the
academic side in terms
of the partners that we have.
So, when we first started, again,
we had four partners initially,
so these were launchde these with
the types of organizations
that we're working with.
So, Lloyd's Register Foundation.
They are a charity
themselves and they
own Lloyd's Register which
is an insurance company.
That's a commercial entity
but the profits from
the commercial entity,
as I understand, they
feedback into the charity.
The charity's mission
is to essentially make
the world a safer place
in which to live.
I guess that benefits the
insurance arm of
the organization.
So, Lloyd's Register
particularly interested in,
they call it data-centric
engineering.
So, engineering of
critical national
infrastructure to ensure
the safety and integrity of
those infrastructure,
maximize that.
Intel, marine tested and
co-designing chipsets
and new algorithms.
I guess the generating
optimized the sales.
I lead the interaction
primarily with
these organizations,
so GCHQ which is the UK
equivalent of NSA,
our Ministry of Defense and
the Ministry Defense
research arm which
is Defense Science
Technology Lab, DSTL.
Then finally, one of
our partners was HSBC.
I've been told many stories
about HSBC, but allegedly,
HSBC has 20% of
the world's financial transaction
trade flow data going
through the books,
so that's quite a lot
of data and they want
to do lots of things
with that data.
So, there's a co-partnership
happening with HSBC.
I will go through all of these
because I realize
it's a little boring.
The partnership with Microsoft
is one way of presence,
so we're very grateful to
Microsoft for providing us with
a million pounds
worth visual credits
here to do cool stuff,
but that's where the relationship
gives a million pounds worth of
credits and lots more.
So, part of my motivation for
being here is to try
to reach out beyond
those usual credits and
make some meaningful attempt
at collaboration.
Some of you may know
Andrew Blake who was
the director of Microsoft
Research Cambridge
as I understand it.
A few years ago he was
our initial director
at the Institute.
Andrew is now moved on to
bigger and better
things I'm told.
So, there is a link
between MSR and MSL
Cambridge at least on
the Institutes in London,
but like I say, I'm really keen
to develop those relationships.
So, as I go through
this presentation,
if anything takes your fancy
then please do contact me.
I can arrange to link you up with
the specific academics
or a more general level.
So, in terms of how
we're structured,
how many people we hav,
we're not at the MSL size sadly,
but we do have
a reasonable amounts
of people at least
by UK standards.
So, we have 250 or over
250 Turing Fellows.
So, we have to use
the word Turing in
front of everything.
That's the brand that
we attach ourselves to.
So, what that mean,
that means that we
succumbed in academics
from our 13 partner universities.
So this would be professors
all the way through to
junior academics working
with us for one, two,
three days a week on
specific research projects
or doing simple teaching with us
or appearing on House of
Lords committees or trying to
shape public policy and do
lots of different tactics.
We actually get them
to do quite a lot
of work for us in lots
of different ways,
and it's amazing
academic community.
So, from the 13 best
UK universities
we then selected 250,
so best academics in
this area to work with us.
So, we have a really
great people of
academics working with us
and some of the names,
I won't list them because
I don't want to show
you demonstrate
my favorite academics but some of
the names I hope you
will come across.
We have 19 of
our own research fellows which
really translates into postdocs.
We have about 50 PhD students.
We have an internship program
which is running at the moments
which I'll come back
to at the end of
the summer period.
We have quite a lot of
visiting researchers
from academia, industry,
and government.
The UK government in
response to Brexit has
introduced a scheme called
the Rutherford Fellows.
What that is trying to do
is to demonstrate that the UK is
an open country which I
hope we always will be.
They fund senior,
great academics,
or great researchers
not academics,
great researchers from
around the world to
come and spend up to
a year in the UK working at
different research
organizations or in industry.
So the Turing Institutes has
been given quite a bit of
money to attract lots
of people in the UK.
So, we've got six or seven people
from the US actually come across,
so people from statisticians,
for instance, from CMU
are working with us and
spending six months
or so with us.
So, if there's
any interest in that,
I'm not quite sure what
Microsoft position on that would
be but if that's of interest
then we have the ability
to find people to come
across and spend a
reasonable amount of
time working with us.
We have our own, we call
them research engineers,
software engineers
that are of more
academically minded than
your average software engineer.
We have a reasonable
size admin team
because to manage 250 academics,
you almost need
500 size admin team
but we didn't go to
that order of magnitude,
we settled at 50.
We have seven program directors.
So, I'm one of the program
directors at the institute.
We will have eight eventually.
That aligns to our aid programs
and the challenges.
So, the program
directors essentially
control or lead the research of
the institutes aligned to
one of these eight
thematic areas.
This is a slide that's been
created by the
marketing department,
so you can suddenly
get less and less technical as
the marketing department
get more and more involved.
I should remember that this has
been publicly released as well.
Just in case
the marketing department
watch this presentation,
it's a great fantastic slide
but it's not the most technical
slide I've ever given.
So, we're doing work
in health care.
As I mentioned, we're
doing work in engineering.
I lead the work that
we do in security.
We do work on economics
using HSBC data but again,
focusing on our charts
full of [inaudible] around
social good and education.
We have quite a big interest
in ethics and making machines,
seeking decisions fair,
transparent and ethical.
I touched upon this in terms of
our interactions with Intel,
and designing computers and
chipsets and algorithms,
kind of co-designed in those too.
We are doing work in
science and humanities,
and we are trying to foster
government's innovation.
I've still not figured out
what that actually means.
But we're trying to make
government more efficient
in every sense of the word.
So, as you guys, I'm sure,
know, statistics, data science,
artificial intelligence,
call it what you like,
computer science I suppose,
has general applicability.
And we will set up as
these national institutes to
derive benefit from
all the work that we undertake.
And so what we decided
to do was focus on
these eight application
areas essentially.
We believe, with
the partners that we have,
if we do make positive impacts in
one or more of these
eight areas then we'll
be able to meet
our charitable objectives.
So we focused on eight areas,
which doesn't feel like that much
focus because actually each one
of these areas is huge in itself.
But it's a level of focus.
Is as much focus as we can
give ourselves at present.
We have a little bit
of technical focus.
Although the scientific strategy
is still emerging,
and I will kind of propose
a scientific strategy
or rather a focus where I
think the institute is
best placed to contribute
scientifically.
And that builds on Alan
Turing's legacy, in my opinion,
or one of his many contributions
to the scientific literature.
But I'll come on
the slide in a moment.
In terms of some of the applied
research projects, so,
again I have just given you
a very high level overview of
the types of things
we're doing and if
any of these are of interest,
the publications on our websites,
and we open-source all of
the software that would generate,
so essentially everything.
We believe in reproducibility,
we believe in openness, etc.
So we're trying to push
everything out there
so that people
can benefit from the
work that we do.
So, just to give you
a little bit of insight
into the work that we do.
Some of them are
self explanatory.
Digital twin this is related
to the work that
we're doing with
large register foundation.
So, apparently there's
a 3D printed bridge
being placed in Amsterdam.
The printed sensors are all
over this bridge and is
quite cool video that I
don't have on my laptop,
this bridge actually
being printed.
But they don't really
understand, as I understand it,
they don't really understand
the long-term
structural integrity
or structural properties
of this bridge.
And how it is going to degrade as
a function of time and so on.
But there are instruments in
it with lots of sensors and,
so this project's all
about trying to make
sense of that data
and making sure that
the bridge can hold
people or vehicles or wherever
it is trying to hold.
So, it's quite an important
project from that perspective
but as we start to 3D
print more bridges,
which is expected
to happen in time,
we need to be able to
understand the types of
data that come in from
this type of system.
The national economy dashboard.
So, this is where we're
utilizing the HSBC data,
so this is, the UK government,
I am told, has a good
understanding of
how much trade flows say
between the UK and the US,
because we know how much
stuff goes over our borders.
But actually they don't know
how much trade flows
between London and
Manchester because this is
not an easy way of
measuring that.
So, the HSBC data
it gives us a proxy
to measuring and
trade flows between
different geographical
areas in the UK,
and that allows us
to essentially to
produce local GDP figures almost,
and optimized national
level economic strategies
associated with,
and the different flows
of trade for instance,
between different major
cities in the UK.
That's given the finance parts of
the governments an ability
to optimize their interventions,
and I'm sure it was
a political dimension to that,
but I would hope that they make
all the decisions based on the
data that's in front of them,
versus, but that's
not always the case.
I guess I will go through
all of these because I realize
it's kind of a bit dull and
I've sat in the audience
listening to
these kinds of talks myself,
so I won't bore you too much.
But like say if there's
anything on that slide
that is of interest then
please do contact me,
or visit our website
turing.ac.uk and you can
find out more details.
In terms of the work that I lead,
and I ask the academics
or work with the academics
to undertake this,
I've got three
multi-year research
projects happening at present.
And so GUARD, I think what
we did here was actually,
get the acronym and then
figure out what the name of
the project was retrospectively.
Anyway, essentially GUARD is
about predicting conflicts.
So, it's a combination of
graph theory and
incorporating into
those graphical based
representations
some stochastic
differential equations,
and model things as
a function of time.
And integrating lots
of different datasets,
to be able to predict
areas that are
susceptible to conflict.
And that could be, so we've been
working with the Colombian
governments for instance,
on looking at
different drugs cartels
and how they interact,
or how they shoot each other,
and then suggest
intervention strategies based
on the geographical topology,
and some of the work
that we've been
doing, and saying right okay,
if you insert a roadblock
in this location and
that's likely to
reduce the amount
of shootings or interactions
between these different groups,
and all the way up to
the international levels in
these types of
areas are likely to
be susceptible to
conflicts in the future.
Critically, because
I'm a Bayesian
and obviously I applied
prior distributions
over everything and we
quantify the uncertainty
with everything that we do.
Which is kind of cool.
So, a project starts and
interaction between Warwick,
so Turing Institute
Warwick University
and University College London.
AIDA is a bit like
DARPA's D3M project,
but is on a completely
different financial scale,
as you'd expect
because when DARPA
invest they invest
big whereas when we
invest we invest proportionately
to how much money we
have got in the bank.
So, in this project,
there's an interaction
between Cambridge,
Edinburgh and Oxford Universities
and the Turing Institutes.
And basically what we're
trying to do is to
semi-automate parts of
the data wrangling process.
So, we're looking at, is a lot
of Gaussian process stuff.
If you've seen
Zoubin Ghahramani talk about
the automated statistician and
model selection in
Gaussian processes.
Essentially that's kind of
what we're doing in this space.
And then finally, in
terms of, on this slide,
computing in
untrusted environments,
so what we did in
there is utilized in
Intel's SGX, and technology.
So we've we've just released
a SGX compliant
Linux kind of library.
So, SGX-LKL,
or LKL-SGX, can't remember
which way around it is.
Sitting on top of that SGX
compliant Linux kind of library
we've actually placed Spark,
and you may think that's
a trivial operation but
the memory footprint
in SGX is quite small,
and so the interactions
that one has to
do to get Spark sit in,
and even just the JVM
sitting inside of SGX,
sitting in essentially
an encrypted memory,
is quite significant and
so what that has now given
us an ability to do,
is to run secure
containers essentially,
in cloud-based
infrastructure, and
scale out using Spark's
scalability properties.
Essentially we've got
full end-to-end encryption now,
we've got encryption at rest,
and we have encryption
using SGX when
data and processing
capability is in memory.
So, that's quite cool.
So, we're partnered with them,
that's Cambridge,
Imperial College,
Turing Institutes and we have
interactions with
Docker, and in fact,
we have interactions with
MSL Cambridge on
that particular project too.
So, that's what in there,
and I promise I'll get to
some kind of technical contents
at some point soon.
Then, I've kicked off,
I watch a lot of these
projects now ended,
but I kicked off a bunch of
projects and short projects.
Those previous projects are
all multi-year projects.
These were all
six-month projects.
So, Adversarial
Machine Learning is
of great interest to many people.
What we do in there is
based in deep learning,
and not just because
I'm a Bayesian.
Actually, the guy that run
these projects is also Bayesian,
so that's why I thought
that was a great idea.
So, there's a natural
combination of things,
but what we're doing there is
essentially spotting
hours of distribution,
data points, and
quantifying the probability
that those kinds of data points
are adversarial-related
or adversarily-generated.
We've been doing some work
with the National
Cybersecurity Center.
So, GCHQ has an arm of GHCQ,
which is called the National
Cybersecurity Center,
and they're tasked with ensuring
the UK is safe from
a cybersecurity perspective.
So, we've been doing
some core work and run demark,
analyzing demark data
and analyzing
different interesting data sets
to characterize the UK
governments web footprint.
You may think that's
easy, but actually when
a fire station in the middle
of the countryside,
in the middle of
nowhere, in the UK,
sets or pay websites on GoDaddy,
or wherever, and pays them £20,
you don't necessarily always know
that that website's been created,
and from a central
government perspective,
yet you're responsible
for ensuring
that the government
is responsible for
ensuring that it's
protected to some extent.
So, we've been trying to help
them to understand network.
The final piece I'll touch upon
is evaluating
homomorphic encryption.
We've just open-sourced
a software platform,
which we call SHEEP.
I can't remember what
the acronym stands for,
but it's one of
these most recursive acronyms.
What that is, it's
taken homomorphic
encryption primitives.
So, the addition,
multiplication operations,
and the different
implementations of those,
and actually providing
a benchmarking platform,
through which people when
the clever
mathematicians generates
a new FAG-related algorithm,
they can push it on this
platform and they compare and
contrast their
runtime performance,
as well as some of the
mathematical assumptions that are
baked into these
different algorithms.
So, we noticed that in the
multiparty computation worlds,
there's a benchmarking platform,
but there wasn't one
in the FAG world,
so we've now generated
this platform.
There's a paper just ICML
on this platform.
Hopefully, we'll see
some adoption of that.
So, the reason I mentioned
that is, obviously,
it's a bit of advertising
with thoughts of interest.
If you're an FAG person,
then please do have
a look at SHEEP
and see whether it's
of interest to you.
So, what I tried to do is
cover not so quickly, so
I apologize for that.
Quite a lot of the work that
we did at the Institute.
I didn't really
touch upon some of
the ethics side of things
and some of the most social
sciences side of things,
partly because that's not
my technical background.
I would do them
a disservice if I
tried to explain
what we're doing in
the area of data ethics,
but within the law on
that side of the spectrum.
Working with lawyers, working
with more of the kind
of philosophers,
as it were trying to
help the government and
organizations of different kinds,
and show that they use data in
an ethical and legally
compliant manner,
and changing the UK law such
that we are ethically
responsible in the use of data.
That's quite an interesting area
from a cybersecurity perspective.
There is something that I've
recently been thinking about.
So, I wouldn't say anything
profound at the moment,
but I think it's
an area that we should,
for those of you that are
cybersecurity related research,
you should start to think a
little bit more than we
currently perhaps do.
So, I'll start the segue
now into a bit more
of a technical content.
So, I was interested,
so I joined the Alan Turing
Institute for many reasons,
partly because it's
a national institute in the UK,
and partly because of the brand,
the brand of the man himself,
and the brand of
the university partners
and the institute essentially
trades off all of those brands.
That's what gives us
great convening power and
also allows us to create
national level impacts.
I was interested in
Alan Turing and what he did,
so I started to
read some papers of
his and papers that
were written about him.
It turns out, you may
suspect I would say this,
that Alan Turing himself
and I'll cast him,
perhaps maybe not one
of the first British,
certainly one of
the first data scientists
that I've come across.
That's through my limited
reading in history.
He was a statistical
data scientist,
specifically at Bletchley Park.
Why do I say that?
Well, I'll give
you some citations
and some quotes from him
to demonstrate that
that's partly true.
But if data science
is the combination
of different
scientific disciplines
to derive value from data,
then Turing and his work
at Bletchley Park, essentially
that's what he did,
so in Hut eight at Bletchley
Park, he had linguists.
He had, I guess
the first computer scientists.
He had hardware engineers.
Quite crucially, he had
Jack Good as a statistician,
which was helping to guide
him towards the boundaries,
MAS algorithm, all the work they
did in deciphering Enigma.
So, I propose that, or rather,
the literature and I proposed
that Turing was
a statistical data scientist,
so the institute has
quite a natural link back
to Turing and his work.
Then, if we focus in
on Alan Turing's view
of probability.
So, there is a really cool paper.
Back in 2012, Alan Turing
appeared on archive,
which is not something
that happens every day.
When you get notifications
on you that Turing's just
appeared on archive,
but GCHQ kindly,
openly published, declassified,
and openly published
a paper of Turing's in 2012.
You can go on
the Internet and download
this either from archive because
somebody's typed it
up where you can see
the original manuscripts,
which was handwritten.
The paper by Turing,
which was written in 1941,
but suddenly published in 2012,
it's titled
The Application of
Probability to Cryptography.
My mathematical knowledge,
being a statistician,
isn't as great as
I'd like it to be.
Well, I actually do
understand the cryptography
that goes on in this paper,
but I don't fully
understand cryptography
in any meaningful sense,
but I do understand
the probability side
of things that he
presented, thankfully.
Some of the key quotes
that come from this paper.
Actually, there's a great guy,
a great US-based academic
head called Sandy Zabell,
who has done quite a lot
of work on the history of
Turing and provided
commentary on this paper,
which so if you're
interested in this paper,
I suggest you also read
this accompanying paper,
which provides a commentary.
It's actually Sandy Zabell
that pulled out some
of these quotes.
So, this, to me,
is evidence that
Turing was a Bayesian,
is a Bayesian, was
a Bayesian, I guess.
The use of Bayesian statistics
through World War II was actually
the key thing that
helps us to decipher
Nick Moon allegedly win the war.
So, on Bayesian statistics,
if I extrapolate
Bayesian statistics
and Bayesian methodology
helped to win the war.
That's quite
extraordinary, given that
Bayesian statistics in the '40s
was seen as something
that one should never do.
So from my heart,
it's further off to
Alan Turing for actually
persevering with
the Bayesian methodology
in utilizing this
in the way that I'll
describe in a moment
released at high level.
Turing said in his manuscript,
the probability of an event
on certain evidence
is the proportion of
cases in that which an event
may be expected to happen
given that evidence.
So, that loosely suggests
that he's a Bayesian.
He's thinking about
conditional probabilities.
That's my interpretation
of that statement.
But then more specifically,
he talks about the evidence
concerning the
possibility of an event
occurring usually
divides into a part
about which statistics
are available,
i.e., a likelihood function,
under less definite parts
about which one
can only use one's judgments,
i.e prior knowledge.
We combine those in
a mathematically rigorous way,
as you all know, because I'm sure
some of you are Bayesians
in this audience.
Well, I hope you are. We
get posterior distribution.
So, that suggests
Turing was Bayesian.
Actually, what really
suggest Turing was
a Bayesian was the quotes which
directly states
that nearly all applications
of probability to
cryptography depend
on the factor principle
or Bayes theorem.
So, back in 1940's,
Bayesian statistics
have been used.
Essentially, what we're computing
was Bayes factors and
we introduce some cool
computational tools, the deciban.
Deciban was introduced
basically in the same way that,
the computer scientists
in the audience
was used computational tricks
to improve computational
tractability.
The deciban was introduced
back in the 40's to
do exactly that.
So, some cool things that we
do now almost naturally as
a data science community
that they would do in
Hut eight back in the
1940's which I find
quite inspirational.
Again, there's another
great paper by Jack Good.
This stuff, the
work that they were
doing in Hut eight
really started to not
leak but started to appear in
the open literature
around 1980's.
Again, Jack Good, I have
infinite respect for these
kinds of academics who
were utilizing big proponents of
these kinds of methodologies that
were completely out of favor.
During the period,
and during the 40s,
and yet they persevered.
They knew that this
changed the course of
the war in specific ways
in which they utilized
relative simple ways,
these methodologies,
and they were constantly told by
the rest of the academic
community that
Bayes in statistics was
just not useful in any way,
shape or form, and
yet they had to keep,
that's bite the lip and not
actually release
any of this stuff.
So, it's remarkable.
I'm not sure I would have
the self-control to be able
to not leak all
secret. Maybe, I shouldn't
say that actually.
I have the self-control, just
in case anybody's watching.
So, that leads me to take
on my interest which is,
I want to be able to build
a Bayesian model for
cyber-security or,
specifically in
this context network-based
cyber-security.
I think there are four key things
that we need to learn about,
and I have not done
any of these yet.
I should say that in writing,
beginning this journey.
I might be interested
in anybody's
thoughts in any of these things,
and I'll allude to
the problems that sits
within these things.
So, I think the key
ingredients are as follows;
so Chain Event Graph essentially,
a way in which one
can undertake causal,
specifically Bayesian
analysis but
causal statistical analysis,
and represents the causality
between events using game.
Event trees, and this is a
general Chain Event Graphs.
So, a generalization
of event trees,
for those of you that
don't know them,
and eliciting great
expertise from people like
Johnson and others about
cyber-security systems
by adversaries about
how they work,
about systems of systems,
about supply chains et cetera,
building all of that into
quite a complicated statistical
causal Bayesian model using
this Chain Event Graph
methodological system
to represent what's going
on in the real world.
So, that's the incorporation
of prior knowledge as it were.
So, I'm particularly interested
in Chain Event Graphs,
so I just started a project
which is actually
looking not
cyber-security at all,
but I'm hoping it will
translate into that.
So, I've started a project
using Chain Event Graphs,
which is looking at how
an individual will go
from minor radicalization
to full radicalization,
to taking part in
some terrorist related attack in
Western country and looking at
the sociological
evolution as it were,
an individual's
psychological and the
sociological surroundings
evolution through
that path from being somebody
like myself all the way
through to somebody being very
radicalized and now I'm
performing in stack.
That has analogies in
some respects to
the cyber-security kill chain.
So, I'm hoping that
the learnings from
that work will translate
across into the cyber world.
So, we've got the ability
to do causal inference assuming
that this stuff works.
The next thing I'm interested in
is horizontally
scalable inference.
So, I am particularly
interested in scalable
statistical methods.
So, things that sit on top
of platforms such as Spark.
What I see, a lot of the time in
Spark-related applications
is that people
like to count, and that's great.
We do a lot of summarization
through counting a lot of things.
But that's not
the most sophisticated one
can do with respect
to statistics.
So, what I want to do is to get
most statistical sophistication
to Spark-like environments.
So, we're currently
starting a project,
an open-source projects
that complements Spark ML,
MLlib, sorry, which is
looking at place in MCMC,
Markov Chain Monte Carlo related
algorithms on top of Spark,
and so there's some
interesting challenges that
exist when you're
trying to perform MCMC.
You've got distributed datasets
across multiple machines,
you're running
local MCMC algorithms
computing local
posterior distributions,
or sample-based representations
of those posterior distributions.
How do you combine those
samples to produce
a globally consistent and
statistically correct
MCMC algorithm
or rather representation up
asymptotically correct
representation
of the posterior distribution,
and that's what this
project's all about.
So, we just started
quite a big project as
a collaboration
between Cambridge,
Warwick, Oxford and Bristol,
and the Turing Institute
on just that topic.
The best thing we've come up
with so far is quite a kill,
rejection sampling algorithm,
which is this perfect
sampling all kinds of things.
We'll be publishing
that very shortly.
Computationally, it's horrendous.
It's just some Spark.
So, we have the
horizontal scalability.
It takes quite a while just
to do one MCMC iterations,
so there's still quite a lot of
research to do in this space
but we do have ideas
around how we can
speed these things up.
Handling time-varying phenomena.
I mentioned earlier on
that I'm interested
in things as function times
sequential Monte-Carlo et cetera,
and that's going to be the focus
of the last few slides
that I've got.
In the moment, there's
some point process
work that I've been doing.
I'm using Markov much
and Poisson processes,
which Josh has seen
now about three
times in this presentation,
so I apologize Josh.
Then, finally, I think
the final key ingredients of
a good cyber-security model or a
good cyber data
science related system
should be that the techniques
are privacy preserving.
So, I mentioned
homomorphic encryption.
We just kicked off
another project which is
looking at FHE-based algorithms,
and essentially I'm trying
to produce homomorphicly,
that's not the correct
phrase, HE algorithms,
that's a classification
algorithms.
So, for instance, there's been
a paper that demonstrates
a logistic regression
algorithm that is
fully homomorphic
encryption compliance,
if that's the correct phrase.
We want to take that
a bit further, so,
logistic regressions
is useful but
it's not most sophisticated
thing we can do.
So, how do we take
that project and go to
the next class of statistical
classification algorithm
using homomorphic encryption,
so this project's
known as Crypto-ML.
Again, we're looking
for collaboration
opportunities on
that project too.
So, such collaboration actually
it's just a collaboration
between
the Heilbronn Institute
for Mathematical Research,
which is based in Bristol,
and Warwick University
assistance,
and the Turing Institute.
So, for me, if we can combine
all of these four things,
we have ability to respect
people's privacy and
utilize as much of the data on
the different end-user
devices as possible,
but respect the privacy.
We can handle time-varying model,
we can operate at scale and
looking cross computers,
and we can incorporate
prior knowledge.
If I can combine
these desperate things,
and they're still desperate
as it stands today,
I think we've got
quite ecosystem.
I don't know how far away
in terms of time
we are from this,
but this is my vision and this is
the work that I've kicked off and
the work that I'm
doing personally.
I hope to integrate all of
these and stand here in,
say five years time and give
you a much better presentation.
I remember when I stood
here five years ago.
Now it integrates
all these systems
have come up with it's all
open-source please rip it
apart and tell me where
I can improve in.
If you think any of
those ideas are wrong,
or you've got
any complimentary ideas,
or you just want to chat to me,
then again my e-mail address
is at the end and I welcome
the opportunity to chat to you
via Skype or Zoom or wherever.
I guess Skype will
be the favorite to.
>> Teams.
>> Teams, okay. So, I
believe some of
my colleagues from
Imperial have spoken here before.
So, I won't repeat
that presentation.
So, now I'll focus in on
a little project that I did with
one of my students
at Imperial College.
Around the use of
NetFlow data, analyzing
NetFlow data.
I'm trying to understand
user behavior on
a particular device
using a particular class
of model point,
process model known as
a Markov-modulated
Poisson process,
and show you some results,
some kind of the presentation
really started off
quite broad in terms of
the [inaudible] institute and
I'm just narrow it down to
this particular
NetFlow-based analysis.
So, we are at Imperial College.
I'm collecting NetFlow data.
We have about 40,000 computers.
We generate about 12 terabytes of
Flow data per month or around
15 gigabytes per hour.
The kinds of things
we're interested in,
so we're interested
in people trying
to steal our
intellectual property.
Because for Imperial,
that's one of the ways in
which we can generate
revenue and obviously,
then, fund the academic research
that we also undertaken,
the training that we do.
We don't want to impose
lots of constraints
on the network.
Academics get grumpy when
you tell them they can't go
and visit a particular website
and [inaudible] website is.
Students in college halls
really don't like being told
that they can't use the latest
illegal file sharing too.
Not that anybody does that at
Imperial College, I'm sure,
but that's a consideration too.
Spearfishing turns out
as often the case,
is a major compromise roots
for the network.
I guess the four things which is
always the case with
cyber security.
The brand damage that
one could incur if
there were attack,
successful attack, or if
such an attack was reported,
I'm sure there has been several,
several successful sites.
You just don't know
about them. So, I
guess some of you
will know this stuff,
but NetFlow record is
somewhere between
two network devices.
It's collected at
the router level as
quite a quite a lot of
interest in statistical
issues around missing data,
around duplication,
around direction,
around time, around
synchronization.
There's lots of change going on,
and there's lots of ways
in which you can
analyze the data.
So, NetFlow data is
really cool dataset from
a statistical perspective.
If you're interested in
developing statistical
methodology,
and that's kind of
my interest really,
then this offers quite a lot of
different statistical problems to
motivate the methodological
developments
that one can undertake.
The great dataset, the
Los Alamos National Labs
released is a great dataset
for everybody to kind of access,
but I'm sure, and I saw you
have access to
some great data too.
So, maybe, you don't need
that open-source data,
but I will advertise
the Los Alamos data,
not least because I'm visiting
Los Alamos next week.
If anybody's watching this,
they will be pleased I've
advertised the datasets.
So, given NetFlow data,
I have given, metadatas are
about the packets flying
across the network.
What I want to do is just
analyze an individual device,
and I want to [inaudible]
use of behavior.
So, I want to know, just from
the timing information of
the events on the computer,
can I figure out what
the user was doing,
were they streaming,
were they are on,
not necessarily were
they on YouTube,
but were they streaming video,
were they writing emails,
were they doing nothing at all.
What kinds of activity
were they doing?
So, I want to come in further
using a Bayesian process.
The Bayesian process
I've chose to use
is a Markov Modulated
Poisson Process.
What is an MMPP?
Well, really simply,
what we've got is a,
this is some other kind
of more formal detail,
but I won't go through this
in the interest of time.
What we have is a hidden,
a latent continuous
time Markov chain,
which is denoting or
rather representing
the user behavior.
So, we've got a finite state,
continuous-time Markov chain.
So, if the chain
is in state zero,
the user's inactive and if
the state is in chain one.
If the chain is in state one,
then perhaps the wrong
video streaming websites,
and so on and so forth.
So, we have some
interesting challenges
that are both in terms of
specifying the number of states.
We've got a model
selection problem,
linking it back to
Alan Turing's work in
model selection and base factors
and all that good stuff.
So once we solve that problem,
then we have an
inference problem.
We want to infer the state,
what are they doing
on the computer.
I know all our
likelihood function
is essentially
a point process model,
a plus one point process model,
where we get the
event timing data.
From event timing data,
we want to infer
this state of this
continuous-time Markov chain,
and some stuff on
continuous time Markov chains,
which I will skip over
because you're either interested
in it, and you know it.
Or, you're not interested in it,
and it's doormats that
nobody really cares
about, interesting math,
nevertheless.
So, the kind of
key contribution that we made.
The first one was from
an application perspective.
We were able to kind of,
as you'll see on the next slide,
we were able to
demonstrate that one can
infer some stuff from using
these types of methodologies.
The second contribution that we
made was in terms of
parameter estimation,
and so from a
methodological perspective,
and not continuous-time
Markov chain.
What you want to do is to
estimate a bunch of
parameters or two parameters,
which are reasonable
dimension depending on
the number of hidden states
that you have in this
continuous-time Markov chain.
You can do that using
EM or Gibbs sampling,
so it's all relatively
straightforward.
But, from an estimation
perspective,
what you need to be able to do,
is to construct
the smooth distribution.
So, if your state
space modelling,
if you are trying to compute
the posterior distribution as
a function of time as you
get more and more data.
What you need to be able
to do is to compute
this distribution
conditional on all the data.
I've omitted lots
and lots of details,
puts in the accompanying paper.
What we realized is that,
when you're computing
the smoothing distribution,
you run a filter forward
across the data in time.
You want to filter
backwards in time,
and you combine the outputs
of the different points in time.
This backwards filter is actually
not a probability measure.
It needn't be necessarily
a finite measure.
So, when you use
sequential Monte-Carlo
related techniques,
which you have to use
in this particular case
and to estimate
these distributions,
because the solution [inaudible]
admit none of the analytically
tractable solution.
This estimation of this measure,
which is not necessarily
a finite measure,
means that these techniques,
all the convergence theory
goes out to the window.
So the methodological
contribution that we
made in this particular paper was
to guarantee that
the backward filter
is a finite measure.
The very least by introducing
an artificial distribution,
we did some probabilistic
manipulations
to kind of remove
the effects of
some artificial distribution
that we introduced and make
this whole system computable
using the types of methodologies,
sequential Monte-Carlo
we have to use,
which is then embedded
in a parameter
estimation algorithm to
estimate the parameter.
Parameter estimation is very
computationally expensive
once you estimate the parameters,
the actual algorithm
to infer this stuff,
to infer the states of the user,
is actually relatively
straightforward.
So, just to kind of reiterate,
we got point process data.
We want to estimate the states
of this hidden state,
how you actually use
the [inaudible].
We use a relatively simple
algorithm to be able to do that.
That's Markov modulated
Poisson process algorithm to
estimate the probability
of the states
in any one particular time.
Prior to that, we
have to estimate
the parameters of
the system we use,
in our case, we used
Gibbs sampling.
But within that Gibbs
sampling procedure,
we needed a sequential
Monte-Carlo algorithm,
and we realized that there was
this technical problem about
this backwards filter,
not necessarily approximating
a finite measure,
and so we solve that
particular problem as well.
So, that's the
methodological contribution,
then gets applied in
cyber security context.
In this particular case,
I think we went for
a four state, continuous-time
Markov chain.
But I would say,
methodologically, it's
generalizes practically.
If you go beyond 10 states,
then you probably
going to be waiting
a few weeks for your results
to actually be usable.
So, very good question.
So, one was emailing,
one was doing nothing,
one was streaming,
and the fourth one was
on Microsoft Word.
I'm sorry, little advertisement
for your organization
there. Just to see.
So, I can't remember what,
I think these are the different,
so the different
colors represents
the different types of
activity beyond the taken.
So, what we did was
to get the student to do
different activities.
We kind of recorded
the ground truth,
and then we accessed
his NetFlow data from
his device from the college,
and so, this is the counts
of NetFlow data.
I think been over
a five minute time period,
or it might be a minute,
I can't remember
now the exact details.
So, that's the NetFlow data,
and these are the results.
What we do here,
is just focus in on
one part of that data
just to make that,
make it visible.
So, these are
the different states.
This blue line here is
the map estimates of
the state that we believe
the device to be in,
if you believe me.
Then, the estimate estate
is often consistent,
not always, but often
consistent with
the actual true states.
Which, I didn't
believe to be true.
So, I didn't think this was
actually going to work.
I just thought it was
a methodological problem
and it was a homodyne,
I had in my back pocket
at the time,
and I thought, let's try it out.
But actually, we
were able to infer
the true states of the user
on this particular device.
We didn't have any
of the ground tree,
so I don't know how
well it generalizes.
But this for me is
a particularly kind of
important piece of the jigsaw in
this larger Bayesian model
I was talking about,
being able to infer what the
user's doing from just from
NetFlow data with an associated
kind of representation.
The uncertainty is
the key ingredients
in building out this system of
systems based representation
and understanding
what's going on in the system.
>> Right, do you remember
which processing corresponded
to which activity in this?
>> No, off the top
of my head. I'd have
to go back to the paper,
I don't remember top of my head.
>> I was sort of wondering
why Microsoft Word
would generate number data.
Yeah, I was curious
about that too.
So, you could discriminate
Microsoft Word from
no activity in the data.
>> There is an online
version of Word.
>> That must be where it is.
>> There's several
online versions
of Word in fact I think.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> It could well be
on the OneDrive,
relates the kind of syncing it.
I don't think we're
using the kind of you
know the you go to Chrome or
Explorer over to use and
use the online Word.
But I think you can call
off sync from going on
the background, these days.
>> You use bad Network,
horrible things
happen If your stuff
is in OneDrive.
Therefore, it must
be a good network.
>> So, that's all I wanted
to talk about with
respect to that.
I'm conscious that I'm
running out of time,
but just to reiterate.
So, the Turing Institute is
the UK's national level
Institutes for data science.
Thankfully, Turing's
appreciation of
Bayes helped to change
the world for the better.
I said Turing but actually,
Jack Good's contribution is the
substantial and the team is
shouldn't be underestimated.
As I'm sure, many of you
in the audience know,
there are many
interesting Bayesian
challenges still to be solved.
I've kind of alluded to some
of them in my presentation,
and those are kinds of things the
activities that were undertaken.
Specifically, under my direction.
And as you know big data
or all deep learning,
deep reinforcement,
learning deep something.
Does not necessarily mean
that statistical or
expert knowledge is not needed,
and so I'm still
I'm still gonna fly
the Bayesian flag even in
the world of deep learning.
I think the deep
learning community
and people I know in
the deep learning community,
are kind of caught on
to that and trying to
integrate expert knowledge into
the systems and are developing.
In this presentation,
I introduced
a very simple Bayesian model.
It's not quite what
I wanted to present,
it's not quite what
I wanted to do.
In terms of, it's not as
far as I'd like it to be.
But I still think
it's quite cool,
and will solve
some interesting problems.
I hope this is
demonstrated to an extent
the kinds of work
that we're doing,
puts Turing Institute at
the forefront of research
in modeling and inference.
Specifically, Bayesian
modeling inference,
we have quite a strong community
in Bayesian statistics.
For me personally,
I think, you know,
I always think it's good
that an institute should be
recognized for doing
something quite well.
Let the vector institutes in
my mind is great
at deep learning.
Primarily, because
the people they've
got associated with
that Institute.
For me, we've got some really
great Bayesian people and
I'd like the institute to become
famous for Bayesian-related
statistics.
But again, that's partly because
I'm biased in terms
of my background,
but I think it has
quite a nice segue way
to many different attributes
while ensuring books.
Specifically, it's working
probability theories.
Then finally, I've
mentioned collaborations,
visits, presentations
are welcome for me.
From me personally,
come and visit me,
or come and visit any of
our academic community
and I'll set up
those interactions.
We can do that virtually,
or we can do that physically.
I welcome your
interactions of any kind.
These are my two email addresses
please do email us all,
if you're not inclined,
follow us on Twitter.
But, thank you for
your time today and,
I welcome any questions
you may have.
>> So, mode of selection
problem. It's tough, right?
So, Net Flow, it's
all over the place.
Some day I just have
humans on them and
others are just purely
machine driven,
and they look a lot
different, you know?
Adversities switch there's
a Markov processor,
others are very smooth.
So, can you talk a little
about how you approach
your model selection there?
>> In that case, no.
I've not approached
it but, what I do,
I would probably come up with
some kind of hierarchical
representation,
so that I have an indicator as to
the type of device
that the machine is.
So, when I'm performing
the statistical inference,
in the way that I described
of the condition on
my inferred states
of that machine.
I use a server as
an access devices it,
and, is it some cloud-based
bespoke thing doing
something weird.
So, I would produce an
additional level of obstruction,
introduce another latent variable
in the true Bayesian way
and solve that particular
problem there.
>> That sounds,
that's very consistent
with what I think as well.
This probably read
into you before that,
which is they figured out
all the different
categories that might be
involved in the mixture,
so just servers in laptops
or is it printers,
laptops and servers or you know?
What is the resolution at which,
you want to have
the mixture, the result to?
You can do this with users
and machines and processes?
All of these have sort of
a mixture behavior
to them so, yeah.
>> That's where
interactions start.
That's where the human dimension
discman and expert knowledge,
you need to talk to the guys
that own the network.
At least, get their view
on what's on the network.
They may obviously, not
always know what's
on the network.
But I think, having
those interactions you
can then better model the world
and incorporate the uncertainty
associated with those models.
So again, how I can replicate
the Bayesian methodology.
I feel like I've hammered
that point a little bit
too much today.
I am pragmatic most of the time,
but as long as
the Bayesian solution.
>> So, you talked about using
Polymorphic Encryption
and actually
I'm impressed that someone
got logistic progression
to work there.
It seems like should
be really hard
because exponentiation
is not a ring operation.
But you can say you
can evaluate using
polymorphic encryption
if you want to
do this in some privacy
preserving way.
Of course, then you
would have the answer to
your thing you
evaluated for someone,
but you can only do that if
you get the model from somewhere
and I was wondering if you had
any thoughts about
how that might be
done in a privacy preserving way.
There is hope that one
might be able to build
a model using encrypted data,
but it's always off
and the data has all
been encrypted with the same key
in all the schemes I've heard.
>> So, no is the short answer.
Because, I rely on
my colleagues to do
that work for me or with me.
So, no I don't have a sensible
answer to that question.
So, I'll avoid
the question completely.
Hopefully, if any of
my colleagues are
watching then they
can email me and say,
"This is what the answer to
that question should have been."
>> That'd be great.
>> So, no, I can't give you
an answer to that question.
>> One take away is were very
interested in
polymorphic encryption.
So, that's probably a real key
collaboration opportunity.
>> Yeah, okay.
>> There are some
awesome experts in
that in this building.
>> Certainly, we'll have.
I don't have expertise.
>> I'm not one either,
actually I'm a-.
>> [inaudible] for me.
>> So, you have more
about Spark on SGX?
You're running Spark on SGX?
>> Yes, that's right.
Spark set in on top of
an SGX compliance Linux kind of
library. So, if you Google-.
>> You're running
Spark inside an SGX?
>> Components of Spark. We
have to rewrite Spark or
rather we have to SGX-fy
some specific parts of Spark.
The project really was
about identifying which
parts of Spark needed to
be inside the SGX enclave
and which parts
didn't need to be.
So, we have to make
some subtle changes
to the Spark code base.
>> So, you're trying to be
training, re-eval or both?
>> So, what we're
trying to do is have
a Spark environment
so that users can
do wherever they
want on top of it,
just writing in
standard code in Spark SGX.
The Spark SGX compliant version.
The user's in variance
to the fact that it's
got SGX sitting behind it.
So, as a person that
doesn't want to have to
worry about the kernel-ish
level operations,
that one has to undertake
to get SGX to
actually do anything.
I can just sit there,
write my Scala code in
Spark as I normally
would and be fairly
confident that the SGX side
of things will be
taken care of through
this Linux library and
the Spark modifications that
sits on top of the SGX LKL.
>> Do you have estimates
on how the performance
is related to the SGX version?
>> From memory, I think there's
a five times performance
penalty using SGX,
but I believe Intel are
making some changes to
the next formal release which
should help us with that.
There's still issues
with SGX around such
[inaudible] that
will always exist.
But, I guess, Intel is claiming
that such [inaudible] don't exist.
So, we're not fully secure
in the way that I described,
but nothing ever is.
>> You aren't secure as it is.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, there's
a couple of papers, again,
on our websites and
all this software
now so open-sourced,
so if you're interested
then grab it
and spot the hooks
and countries and
all the other good stuff.
>> I think omission
of the MCMC on Spark?
>> Yeah.
>> So, what kind of
performance [inaudible].
>> What we don't at
present, so we get
a significant time in
significant reduction in
computational performance,
but at least we can then
paralyze across
multiple machines.
So, at the moments I
would argue that one
can't do anything
at all on Spark with MCMC.
You can there's
a couple of attempts at
this using kernel
based approximations
plus you can use
kernel as samples
and then combining those
and I'll call it from my
perspective rather ad hoc way.
So, one can do stuff but
that there's no
asymptotic relationship.
No guarantees that asymptotically
those approximations
mean anything
unless you combine all of
these different approximations.
What we're trying to be
statistically principled
when we combine
these different local
approximations,
but the penalty for
that at the moment is
that costs you a lot
more computationally.
So, the next challenge
is actually how do
we improve the computational
performance of
these quite horrific
rejection sampling
related approaches
that we've proposed.
That's what we'll be doing
next, but in the mean time,
kind of open-source in
all these implementations.
So that at least you know
if you have the time
to wait and you care
about being
statistically principled
then have an ability
to do something.
>> The Spark open- source
committee welcome in such of-?
>> I don't know. We've only
communicates its statistical
community presence.
I guess I need to go to the
Spark conference [inaudible].
The thing that happens
every now and again,
and present it to them there and
see what they say
and the statistical community
seemed to welcome it.
But whether the Spark community
whether they're just happy with
the out-of-the-box machine
learning based algorithms and
a lot of the stuff
seems to be and
SGD related stochastic
gradient descent related and
that may well be
good enough points estimates
for everything,
may well be good enough for a lot
of the applications and so this
stuff's not going to be
relevant so a lot
of the community,
but for those that
actually want to
perform a full Bayesian
statistical analysis.
Which tends to be the case
in my experience in
bioinformatics then this
stuff will be of use.
So, they're the kind of you know,
when books type community.
That community will hopefully
be able to translate and
use this types of technology
relatively easily.
The other thing I should
say is that we're
hoping- I think I can say this.
We are going to be hosting a PPL,
Probalistic Programming Language
workshop next year,
so we've got the stand
community coming across.
We have a tool pyro,
I think it's called.
A PPL language which
sits on top of the JVM.
But so we're getting a number
of different communities
across then hopefully this
stuff will be presented.
It's not a PPL but it's heading
towards that direction which
is why I mentioned them.
Again, if there's any-
I don't know what
Microsoft is doing in the PPL
space if I'm totally honest,
but if there's any interest in
from your community in PPLs
then welcome your involvement
in that workshop too.
Thank you very much.